[Music]
in piety towards the gods i would have
you know the chief element is this to
have right opinions about them as
existing and as administering the
universe well and justly and to have set
yourself to obey them and to submit to
everything that happens and to follow it
voluntarily in the belief that it is
being fulfilled by the highest
intelligence
for if you act in this way you will
never blame the gods nor find fault with
them for neglecting you but this result
cannot be secured in any other way than
by withdrawing your idea of the good and
the evil from the things which are not
under our control and placing it in
those which are under our control and in
those alone
because if you think any of those former
things to be good or evil then when you
fail to get what you want and fall into
what you do not want
it is altogether inevitable that you
will blame and hate those who are
responsible for these results
for this is the nature of every living
creature to flee from and to turn aside
from the things that appear harmful and
all that produces them and to pursue
after and to admire the things that are
helpful and all that produces them
therefore it is impossible for a man who
thinks that he is being hurt to take
pleasure in that which he thinks is
hurting him just as it is also
impossible for him to take pleasure in
the hurt itself
hence it follows that even a father is
reviled by a son when he does not give
his child some share in the things that
seem to be good and this it was which
made polyneices and edoclays enemies of
one another the thought that the royal
power was a good thing
this is why the farmer reviles the gods
and so also the sailor and the merchant
and those who have lost their wives and
their children
for where a man's interest lies there is
also his piety
wherefore whoever is careful to exercise
desire and aversion as he should is at
the same time careful also about piety
but it is always appropriate to make
libations and sacrifices and to give of
the first fruits after the manner of our
fathers and to do all this with purity
and not in a slovenly or careless
fashion nor indeed in a niggerly way nor
yet beyond our means
chapter 31 of the end coridian has a
primarily but not exclusively
theological orientation that is it has
to do with human beings orientation
towards the divine or towards in this
case the gods
and epictetus is going to talk about
piety or in greek eusebius the the right
orientation towards the divine
what he's saying here though like i said
is only primarily not exclusively
about the gods it has to do also
with our relations with other human
beings as we're going to see as we go
through this
so he says in piety towards the gods
this is what i want you to understand
the main thing is this
not to worship not to fear them any of
those sorts of things to have the right
viewpoint about them the as he says
orthos
says and it's translated here as right
opinions we might also translate that as
the correct assumptions about the gods
but it's not just as we see in this
chapter
the correct assumptions about the gods
as in you know what we think of as
religious faith or religious belief
it's also
interfacing with the correct opinions or
assumptions
about everything else so
this is part of a greater totality
what are the opinions that we're
supposed to have
he says that they exist and that they
administer the universe well and justly
that that the universe is is
fundamentally
fair or rational uh it may seem unfair
irrational to us from our limited
perspectives here but if we could take a
broader view
it would actually make more sense to us
and to have uh he says to have set
yourself to obey them and to submit to
everything that happens and to follow it
voluntarily
uh in the
belief that it is being fulfilled by the
highest intelligence so
what he's saying there is we should
approach the cosmos the order of natural
things
as if there is some sort of
beneficent
just
rational intelligence running the show
because that that is what in fact the
stoics did believe they thought that
reason ultimately governed everything
and if we don't grasp that that's in
part not because you know there's a
failure in reason capital r
but because there's a fault with the
limited amount of rationality that we
ourselves have which is a reflection of
that that greater rationality but only a
reflection of it
so he goes on and he says if you act in
this way you will never blame the gods
nor find fault with them for neglecting
you this is a very common problem
in
ancient culture and you can see it not
only in ancient greek and roman culture
but you can see it in others as well and
you can see it in in religious belief
among
people who practice particular religions
even today saying god why did you impose
this upon me what the hell's wrong with
you
you seem to be uh uncaring
this is unfair and we can go on and on
and on and on people do in fact do this
as a matter of fact being a religious
believer doesn't take away
a lot of burdens from people in some
cases in fact you might wrestle with
with god to use a biblical metaphor
so he says
how can you do this now notice what he
says here
he says this result cannot be secured in
any other way
than by
withdrawing your idea of the good and
evil from the things which are not under
our control and placing it those which
are
under our control and in those alone
does that have to do primarily just with
the gods or with the divine whatever it
is that we conceive of as being
transcendent to human beings
or does it have to do with pretty much
everything else across the board well
the answer of course is that this is a
central stoic doctrine we saw this
already at the beginning of the end
caribbean we're going to see it running
throughout the entire work
that there is a fundamental distinction
between things that are in our control
things that are out of our control the
good and the evil lie in what's in our
control the things that are outside of
our control are fundamentally
indifferent and we don't really have a
stake in them now if we get mixed up
about that then we're going to blame the
gods when things don't go the way that
we want because they probably won't go
the way that we want most of the time
so he says
if you think any of those things to be
good or evil
things that are that are not under our
control then when you fail to get what
you want
and fall into what you don't want it's
inevitable
it's inevitable
it's it's sort of necessary that you're
going to blame
and hate those who are responsible for
those results so if you know that a
human being is responsible for your love
life going going to pot and you think
that your love life is where good and
evil really reside
you're going to hate and blame those
people who you think are screwing it up
whether they are or not
if your finances are where you pull
where you locate your good and evil
even though these are things that are
that are strictly speaking externals and
outside of our control and somebody
messes with your finances in any way
whether it's the person who uh you know
imposes an extra tax on you or or you
know some some cost
at a grocery store
all the way up to the person who
controls the economy if there is indeed
anybody who doesn't control the economy
you're going to hate and blame those
people if you think about it in terms of
the cosmos as a whole
and the opportunities that you're given
or the body that you're given well then
you can blame the gods as well right
we might blame other things if we're
more secular minded but he says you'll
blame and hate those who are responsible
for these results
here's where it gets you know very
general
this is the nature of every living
creature to flee from and turn aside
from the things that appear key term
there appear harmful so if we
view something as bad if we view it as
harmful to us then it's natural and
rational that we are going to try to
turn away from it that's what it means
to have aversion and we're also going to
hate that thing we're going to say i
don't like the rain because the rain
comes in and it makes me wet i mean
being wet is not really a big problem
unless there's some other concerns
involved but some people get quite riled
up about that likewise he says
it's the nature of every living creature
and
to pursue after and admire the things
that are helpful or or profitable or
useful
and all that produces them so if we
think that something is helpful for us
if we think that something is valuable
we're going to not only pursue it we're
also going to have a positive attitude
towards it and this is as he says
inevitable this is part of the necessary
way in which our minds work not just
ours but also those of other animals so
he says
it's him it's impossible for a person
who thinks that he's being hurt to take
pleasure or to to be happy about that
which he thinks is hurting him just as
it's also impossible for him to take
pleasure in the hurt itself
if something is damaging us something is
damaging the things that we think are
good or you know
or at least instrumental to goods for us
then we're going to get quite upset
we're going to feel negatively towards
those things
so he says what's an example of this
a father
is reviled by a son when he does not
give his child some share in the things
that the child seem to be good and we
could think of uh you know silly
examples of you know you've seen the
commercial with the bratty kid in the
supermarket who doesn't get the cereal
that he wants or the candy and then
throws a tantrum that's exactly what
epictetus is talking about it's also the
kid who uh and now we're using kid in a
very metaphorical term the young adult
who is not getting from their parent
what it is that they want whether it's
attention
whether it's recognition
whether it's the keys to the car
whether it's being you know having this
paid for or that paid for if they feel
that they're entitled to it and they
feel that it's a good and their parent
is standing in the way of that good even
though they love their parent they will
have a natural tendency to be angry at
them to even perhaps hate them and to
say bad things about them it's similar
with with the gods like he says
he gives examples of polynesias and
italy's these are brothers right and
they're they're fighting over royal
power
can't be shared or at least they thought
it couldn't be shared we have other
classical examples as well from
antiquity where power was not able to be
shared we can say the same thing about
wealth we can say the same thing about
fame we can say the same thing about
affection attention
all these goods that we can compute over
can become sources of contention and
strife
so he says this is why to bring it back
to the gods this is why the farmer
reviles the gods and also the sailor and
the merchant and those who have lost
their wives and children
now notice what he says here for where a
person's interest lies there is also
that person's piety
what is beneficial to that person or
what appears beneficial to them that's
what they're going to have piety about
so if the gods are beneficial to them
and give them the things they want oh
i'm so pious i'm so happy i praise you
to the to the heavens zeus the heavens
that you inhabit
as soon as it turns like the farmer who
doesn't get the rain or you know some
insects come along and blight the crops
what are you doing you stupid god don't
you understand that i need things to go
this particular way
the sailor who gets blown off course
the merchant for whom you know things
don't go the way that they're planned
out we could talk about all sorts of
things
anytime that somebody makes a prediction
and things don't go that way they get
mad at somebody they get they feel upset
and they look for somebody to blame
so
epictetus is saying we should learn to
wean ourselves away
from that kind of orientation
whoever is careful to exercise desire
and aversion as he should
is also at the same time careful about
piety
uh and he says that
if if we're going to get that
fundamental distinction right the other
things are going to fall into place
the last things that he has to say in
this chapter seem to be somewhat
conservative you might say or
traditionalist he says
you know you can go ahead and do
religious rituals
it's always appropriate to make
libations libations are where you'd pour
out a certain amount of liquid whether
it be wine or honey
or you know some other drink and
sacrifices that is very important part
of ancient greek religion
and to give the first fruits the first
fruits are what you harvest first so if
it's you know grain it's the very first
grain if it's actual fruits it's the
first of those if it's animals it's it's
you know whatever it is that you butcher
first
and he says to give the first fruits
after the manner of our fathers and to
do all of this with purity now notice
what else he says
he's not saying that there's any
inherent
you know benefit or rationality to doing
this it's just you know if that's what
you do in your society don't don't rock
the boat there's no need to be a jerk
and you know show everybody how
enlightened you are by not doing it go
ahead and do it if you want to show
piety that way that's fine what matters
is this
do it all with purity cathedrals in a
clean way
and not in a slovenly or careless
fashion
nor indeed in what he calls a niggerly
way which means a stingy way that that's
an old word that comes from norse um and
we we nowadays would say don't be cheap
in doing it if you're going to uh
participate in religious rituals
do so in a you know in a way that shows
your your commitment your generosity
doesn't mean you need to spend an awful
lot but you certainly don't want to be
cheap and he says don't do it beyond
your means
because that's not the point of piety
so you might ask well what is the point
of piety he to go back to the original
discussion that he had it is to have the
right opinions or viewpoints towards the
divine
and to behave according to those
convictions
when you have recourse to divination
remember that you do not know what the
issue is going to be but that you have
come in order to find this out from the
diviner
yet if you are indeed a philosopher you
know when you arrive what the nature of
it is
for if it is one of the things which are
not under our control it is altogether
necessary that what is going to take
place is neither good nor evil
do not therefore bring to the divine or
desire or aversion and do not approach
him with trembling but having first made
up your mind that every issue is
indifferent and nothing to you but that
whatever it may be it will be possible
for you to turn it to good use and that
no one will prevent this go then with
confidence to the gods as to counselors
and after that when some counsel has
been given you remember whom you have
taken as counselors and whom you will be
disregarding if you disobey
but go to divination as socrates thought
that men should go that is in cases
where the whole inquiry has reference to
the outcome and where neither from
reason nor from any other technical art
are means vouchsafed for discovering the
matter in question
hence when it is your duty to share the
danger of a friend or of your country do
not ask of the diviner whether you ought
to share that danger for if the diviner
forewarns you that the omens of
sacrifice have been unfavorable it is
clear that death is portended or the
injury of some member of your body or
exile yet reason requires that even at
that re this risk you are to stand by
your friend and share the danger with
your country
wherefore give heed to the greater
diviner the pythian apollo who cast out
of his temple the man who had not helped
his friend when he was being murdered
what's being discussed in chapter 32
might be a little bit difficult to
relate to for
a present-day audience because he talks
about divination
and you know we do have forms of
divination that people use today some of
them quite ancient uh many of them uh
coming to us from various religions of
the world but
it's not something that i think a lot of
us relate to on a day-to-day basis like
would be the case in ancient culture
if we think more generally about what's
being talked about though
i think we can see how this applies to
our own life and our own cultures much
more easily
what a person is doing in engaging in
divination
is trying to you might say consult the
gods to to get a hold of the people or
the things or the forces that really
decide things and
find out what their what their direction
is what their orientation what their
will is
so you would engage in divination to
find out whether you should do something
or not do something how to view things
we do other things and and
when we do these we often place a
quasi-religious
faith or even let's go beyond that a
superstitious kind of attitude towards
those as if they are revealing to us the
the nature of the forces deciding things
behind the scenes
so divination might not be
you know casting dice before some sort
of god and then seeing what the dice say
divination might be
something like seeing what the people
think you know opinion polls or it might
be
something like taking market sentiment
or it might be you know a bunch of other
things as well
so keep that in mind as we're going
through this
epictetus says you know really when it
comes down to it there's some things
that you should go to divination for
uh and then there's plenty of things
where you don't really need to do that
you can figure it out on your own and if
you're
putting the case before the gods you're
really copping out because you know what
you should do so let's take a look
at what he says says when you have
recourse to divination
remember that you do not know what the
issue is going to be
but you have come to find this out from
the diviner
but
if you are indeed a philosopher
you know
when you arrive
what the nature of the thing is you
understand
the basics of the thing so if for
example you're trying to decide whether
you should be romantically involved with
this person or not
you should understand what the nature of
romantic involvement is before you start
going to
say you know uh
a matchmaker and seeing what they have
to say about it or you know consulting
god in some way saying i'm going to pray
on it well you know before you do that
you should understand the nature of what
it is that you're talking about
and he says there's a lot of things
where once you do understand the nature
it's going to change how you see it
here's an example if it is one of the
things which are not under our control
it's all together necessary that what is
going to take place is neither good nor
evil
so if it really is something that's
under our not under our control and we
want to be consistent stoics we say well
i don't have a stake in this
i may have my preferences but that's
just a sign that i'm not really
committed to this being something out of
my control and if i was being consistent
i would see
that whatever it is that the gods want
or the people want or you know whatever
is behind the scenes wants
things are going to play out the way
they are and it's not going to hurt me
or help me either way
so he says do not therefore bring to the
divine or desire or aversion
don't bring the things that you're
already worked up about and that have
their hooks in you psychologically do
not approach the diviner with trembling
but having first made up your mind that
every issue is indifferent and nothing
to you
but that whatever it may be it will be
possible for you to turn it to good use
and no one will prevent this whatever
the case is going to be
you have some way of meeting it and you
can turn it to some sort of good use
even if it's something that we
traditionally look at as being bad like
uh famine like social disgrace like
poverty all these things can be turned
to some sort of good use
so he says go then with confidence to
the gods as
you would to counselors
people whose viewpoints you trust people
who literally can deliberately
deliberate well the uh
you know the phrase here is host epi
and then he talks about engaging in in
we could call it counsel but we could
also call it deliberation and when we
deliberate we're saying well should i do
this or should i do this and we're not
just you know deciding it on the spot
we're like thinking it through we're
reflecting well if i do this then this
is going to happen and this is good but
this is bad and what about this one over
here we think about the trade-offs we
think about what's incumbent upon us and
when we do that with other people who
really uh have you know as we say our
best interests at heart and and know
what they're talking about we can arrive
at much better uh viewpoints about
things and sometimes when we know what
we should do they can help us to stiffen
our resolve to do it so the gods should
be approached in the same way or
whatever it is that we're going to place
in in the seat of the gods in our own
culture and treat as something we can
approach through divination
so he says
go to to them
as you would to counselors and then
after some counsel has been given you
remember who you've taken as counselors
and who you'll be disregarding if you
disobey
then he talks about socrates and he says
go to divination as socrates thought
that men should do
that is in cases where we don't know the
the answer
if you already know the answer you don't
need to go to divination you're copying
out you're looking for somebody else to
make the decision for you
if you know for example that you should
treat your friend as a friend and you
don't need to go to the gods for that or
have some religious texts to tell you
that you can figure that out by actually
consulting your own heart and your gut
and your head and they will tell you the
same thing yes if you're going to be a
friend to somebody there are certain
things that you ought to do right here's
an example here
um if it's your duty to share the danger
of a friend or of your country then
don't go to the diviner and say well
should i do this because if you're doing
that you're basically looking for an
excuse not to do what you know you're
supposed to do
don't go to the diviner to figure out
whether you should be a good brother or
a good sister or a good husband or wife
uh whatever it is that the diviner tells
you
you already know what the answer to that
is
don't go to the diviner to find out
whether you should be fair in business
dealings the answer is yes
don't go to the diviner for all of these
sorts of things that as he says reason
can tell us the answer to or other
skills or arts other techni
we already have the answers
so he says
um you know if if the if you get an
answer and it's something that you don't
like then you're going to get upset
and you don't want to get upset
but reason already tells us what we need
to do reason for example requires that
even at this risk you're to stand by
your friend if you're going to be a
friend then reason tells you if there's
certain risks that you have to run like
you know getting their back in a fight
or when they're being slandered perhaps
you're being slandered yourself uh being
a friend requires that
so he says
therefore give heed to the greater
divine or the pythian apollo who cast
out of his temple the man who had not
helped his friend when he was being
murdered we learn more by looking at the
examples well certain examples at least
of the gods some of them are quite
unedifying from a stoic perspective but
we learn more by looking at the examples
of the gods supporting justice of the
god supporting temperance of the gods
supporting courage about the gods
supporting and conveying wisdom we learn
more about what we ought to do
in in difficult situations by looking at
those things than we do by going to some
murky process by which the the will of
the gods is going to be exposed to us if
there are things that are totally
uh unknown
then epictetus says that that's okay
socrates thought it was fine to go to
the diviner for that sort of thing
epictetus thinks it's okay we might in
the present think that that's irrational
but again remember the
divination here can mean more than just
the traditional uh greek roman
conception of going to the gods and
finding out answers we might have all
sorts of other ways in which we try to
come up with answers as well but we only
need to do that for the things that we
don't already know the answers to
[Music]
you